pass you like the big
thanks
wow
jokes about calibration
are we allowed to talk right now
[Laughter]
ready
okay great so uh for the final talk
before lunch uh we have simega Bart here
to tell us about online
I guess uh did her PhD at Princeton is
now doing uh did a postdoc at Harvard
the
Rutgers next year
thank you organizers for inviting me to
be able to talk uh uh I'm sumiga and
I'll talk about a recent joint work with
Chris Omar and Adam so this is still a
work in progress and we plan to put it
online in all of weeks if you have any
questions about more technicals email us
or catch Chris or um
um and uh so my talk uh so we will talk
about online setting and Omni prediction
so my talk might be a convex combination
of like parikshit's talk and Dean's talk
uh but it's optimized for this New
Concept so we have a new paper
and uh okay let's start so Omni
prediction is uh as we saw in
predictions uh talk yesterday uh only
the goal of omni prediction is to Output
a single predictor that can be used for
loss minimizations minimization for
multiple losses uh simultaneously and
loss minimization is a very widely used
Paradigm in machine learning uh very
briefly uh for in the Bad setting what
loss minimization asks is is the is as
follows so you are given you you have
samples from a distribution D which the
distribution is over the feature
variables and the labels uh where we are
assuming that labels are binary
variables and then you are given a class
of hypothesis capital f and then the
goal is to
minimize your expected loss where
expected loss is defined as there is a
loss function L and you want to minimize
uh the loss between the the loss that
the function f of x has uh with respect
to the labels Y and now what is this
minimization over it is over this
concept plus uh capital f
um so this is the loss minimization
Paradigm you want to minimize this loss
over this uh optimize the loss over this
class of hypothesis and you can ask this
question for different classes of
hypothesis for different loss functions
for example the very common loss
functions used are the squared loss
function or the exponential loss
function and as we saw in parikshit
stock uh different loss functions will
uh will be optimized by different
functions uh small F in class capital f
so this is the this is what I will
say about the formal setting of loss
minimization and now what is the goal of
only prediction our first attempt is
that you want to Output a single
predicted P that optimizes uh this
optimizes the loss
compared to this compared to this class
capital F for all losses in this class
um
in this class capital l
so we can think of capital L as in this
talk we will think of it as like
Lipschitz convex function so for all
lipstick convex functions is there a
predictor p you know what is the class
capital F uh beforehand is there a
single predictor P that optimizes the
the law the losses for all the losses L
uh when compared to this comparative
class
uh as we saw in prediction stock
yesterday even for even if P of X is the
base optimal predictor let's say its
expectation of Y given X then also you
might not want to
input P of X into L for all losses so
for example if the loss is squared loss
then then then this this is minimized by
minimized at expect P of X is equal to
expectation of Y given X but if the loss
is like uh modulus loss where you are
you are doing y minus P mod of Y minus P
of X then you want to round p of x to 0
or 1. so then the definition of only
prediction is you can do some
simple preprocessing on your predictions
such that the you get a minimizer for
that loss
so for every loss in this class capital
l
this expected loss is minimized when you
do pro appropriate post processing on a
single predictor p and when I say
minimize you are comparing this loss
with respect to uh the loss that the
minimum loss that a function f in this
Capital class F which receives
okay any questions till now
so this is the this this the only
prediction was defined a couple of years
ago and uh as uh and production already
told us about this and he told us that
how to achieve only prediction through
the concept of multi calibration which
was defined like
is five years ago now
so very briefly multi-calibration uh
with respect to a class capital F wants
us that conditioned on a prediction
value V
any function for any function f in the
class capital f x should not be
correlated with Y minus V
this was first studied as a fairness
notion and the idea is that for example
a sensitive attribute should not be
correlated with underscoring
and then the paper or omnipredictor
proved that if a predictor p is
multi-calibrated with respect to a class
capital F then it is only predictor for
all ellipses convex losses for the class
of hypothesis capital f
so this the this is this is all in the
batch setting so this paper uh
all the papers I have talked right now
about the omnipredictive paper and the
multi calibration paper are in the Bad
setting and then our contribution is we
extend to the distribution free online
setting uh which is which is which has
very natural motivations for example
weather predictions we use weather
predictions every day and these are the
predictions that are made in online
setting uh uh I don't know series trying
to figure out what is the probability of
rain every day uh
and um
so what's the goal of online Omni
prediction then we want to find one
predictor that simultaneously achieves
low regret for multiple losses
so
for for the Bad setting we wanted to
minimize the loss but in the online
setting perfect loss minimization is
just not possible uh because you get
even you don't like it in the offline
setting you can see the entire data but
in the online setting you are not able
to see it so you usually in the online
setting you talk about low regret
algorithms where you you want low regret
so now here the similarly instead of
thing like getting perfect loss
minimization we want a One predictor
online predictor that achieves that
simultaneously achieves low regret for
multiple losses
and uh the running example that we will
have in this talk is the example of
forecasting that is like uh forecasting
weather predictions we're making
predictions or what is the probability
of rain and so from now onwards I will
call the predicted as a forecaster so
that we know that we are talking in we
are we are in the online setting
um
okay uh so that that's the that is what
that's our goal uh to achieve this goal
uh we again work with online
multi-calibration and on the way we are
one of our technical contributions is a
new Oracle efficient online
multi-calibration algorithm I will touch
upon this algorithm very briefly uh
during the end of my talk
and finally uh I think this new study of
uh online Omni prediction uh opens up
very a lot of interesting questions
about regular traits uh that uh I want
to convince you and like to work on uh
uh more after this talk
okay
so what's the motivation for uh
motivation for studying
um
studying online only prediction it's
very natural so we all use weather
predictions there's a forecaster that
predicts probability of rain each day
which is used by multiple agents to make
decisions for example there might be a
farmer who wants to figure out whether
they want to plant uh plant their seeds
today or not there might be a official
woman who wants to see whether she
should go fish today or not and then
there might be People Like Us who are
just deciding whether to go to office or
not so this uh so there there are high
stake low stake uh uh uh uh
many people might have high or slow
stakes in the predictions of low rain so
they might have the different agents
have different objective functions which
we call different loss objectives that
they're optimizing for but they don't
want to run an online regret algorithm
per agent so you want to use these
predictions and do some post simple post
processing and still get some low regret
algorithm so this is the motivation for
studying online normally prediction
um
again uh so we we we
want to achieve
our our way of achieving online only
prediction is through online
multi-calibration so let's look at what
what what is known about uh calibration
in the online setting
and
um the calibrated forecast was uh
uh uh was defined in a paper of David 19
David's paper in 1985 yeah sorry for the
agents
have different like utilities or
something like why does the same
prediction not work for every agent no
we want the same prediction but they
might have different loss functions
functions so for example one loss
function by might have different
weighting on false positive
unfortunately and that's like fair use
okay thanks
um
okay so this was defined in this so as
uh Dean told us that calibration is
usually thought of as a post processing
that what could we have done but we are
in the online setting we cannot do post
processing we have to make decisions
online so it's not even clear that where
the calibrated forecast can exist uh so
there is a paper that uh I'm sorry that
I didn't cite which said that
deterministic calibrated forecasters
cannot exist
and then uh there are there's multiple
Works uh uh and that showed that uh
existence of calibrated forecasters if
you if your care forecasters are
randomized these these papers go through
a min max argument as we saw in Dean's
talk
um I don't cite Hearts personal
communication because I don't know I was
two years old then
um
okay so this is the uh so so all of
these papers go through a min max
argument either you can go to a missing
Minix argument over the entire time
sequence or at every time step and these
give you different algorithms uh the
existence or explicit constructions for
calibrated forecasters
um uh the the point about min max
arguments is that they are not efficient
and we want to get around the Minimax
arguments and that is what we are trying
to do in this uh paper uh so I will
briefly talk about
um this
um uh the the paper by Gupta at all uh
when when we talk about Oracle efficient
algorithms okay so this is about
calibration what about uh loss
minimization in the online setting so
um there are various Notions of so what
we are trying to do is in general like
we are trying to optimize various very a
lot of different objectives at the same
time right so there are variant notion
of regret in the online at a very serial
setting that optimizes for several
objective functions simultaneously
for example you can look at the sleeping
expert setting adaptive with a great
setting swap regrets it so these all for
example adaptive regret is like you want
to up you want to have low regret for
every consecutive batch of time steps so
most of all these algorithms are looking
at we want are seeking to minimize the
same loss function over different
subsequences of time steps what we are
trying to do is we want to optimize for
different loss functions over the entire
sequence of time steps
so this is the in like if you're if
you're trying to put our work of online
online prediction to this setting of
online adversary early setting of like
different objectives okay
so this is all about like motivation
related related work uh from now onwards
I will start talking about like uh how
to achieve online Omni prediction so
does anyone have any questions
what is the definition of online family
predictions
any other questions
okay so
this is the thanks Michael for that
question so this is the font my formal
online setting
um
we have at the tier time step adversary
chooses a feature comma label pair
a full Caster only sees the feature
vector and it see after seeing the
feature Vector they make they make a
prediction PT
and uh
forecast PT and then after it makes this
prediction it sees uh it sees the label
YT
and then there is a third agent which is
a learner with loss L belonging to this
Capital class L and they what they do is
they use a simple post processing
function to choose an action to choose
an action at the Earth time step
and so 80 the action uh at the peer tank
except for loss L is given by K of L
which is the optimal post processing
function for L of the prediction made by
the forecaster PT forecaster does not
know what is the learner's loss function
but it just knows that it is coming from
this class of capital l
and then
um
so uh this is the this is a learner and
then what is the regret that this
learner sees so the regret is defined as
regret is defined with respect to the
comparative comparator plus capital f
so you look at you look at all the time
steps in the end and then see what what
action should have should I have taken
which function from this hypothesis
class capital F would have minimized my
loss
and you do you want to have low regret
with respect to this minimizer so this
is the loss that you experienced 80s are
80 is your action at each time step and
the loss loss is loss of y t comma 80
and this loss should be small compared
to the minimum loss in F of uh s in
capital f
so this is the regret uh um there should
be I'm yeah if if 80 action 80s are
randomized there would be an expected
regret definition uh but I like for the
talk I'm ignoring the expectations
yeah
so
after seeing also all the actual actions
then no
Nona's loss is defined before uh so it's
for every it's it's fixed for every time
step and it's it's defined for
beforehand
I agree that in the online setting
usually you can choose a different loss
function for every time still well
instead it's a single one yeah
it's only the loss is chosen for all
else so yeah so uh let me tell you to
the quantifiers and then yeah
okay so what is 80 uh
80 is uh 80 is the uh it is the
processing function so we want that uh
so this is the regret for the uh for the
learner which has lost a l
and then what is the definition of
online only prediction we want that for
all l in this class capital l
this regret should be something like 1
by T to the alpha
so usually so as I said we cannot get
perfect loss minimization but usually we
want like sub linear regret such that
Alpha is uh Alpha is like strictly less
than one so that when T goes to Infinity
you are getting perfect loss
minimization so usually like in the
online setting you want sublinear regret
and and this is the uh this is the
definition of omniprediction
um
okay
any questions
um so
if
so just part of the original Omni
predictive paper if your sequence of
predictions is multi-calibrated and this
should give you a 100 yes
yes
yes there are some nuances that we will
talk about the randomization uh no
because of like what is the exact
definition of multiplication we're using
uh we'll see so and and I guess it sort
of um
another natural
candidate definition of wooden Army
predictor
is that uh
the the
longest X you're seeing Bots at every
step and you're given a lot there's a
single decision maker they can be given
any loss uh for any from this class and
they have to make that decision
and I guess it is similar but if you
only get the lossless feedback instead
of the outcome then maybe your host
s
um
so your your forecaster is seeing why as
Speaker
they're not just observing a loss
that's the definition of only prediction
yeah we can let's start with yeah
okay
um so okay so for most for many nine
like nice problems with nice loss
minimization problems with like nice
convex properties you can usually get
one by square root T regret uh for uh uh
and then so the question is like what
are the regret rates that we can get for
Omni prediction and this is I think for
I find it very interesting what are
these what are the lower bounds and
upper bounds for these big red treats
and uh we will see uh we will see them
okay so again so we go through
multi-calibration let's recall what is
the calibration error so a calibration
error for a prediction value V is the
expectation of YT minus V on the days uh
condition on the days that you predicted
B
uh so
in the online setting you cannot get
calibration error to be zero
um and uh so it's it's so we will we
will actually talk about like
but in in terms of errors and not in
terms of like what calibration uh so
okay and then multi-calibration is you
add you add an add an F in this error
and you look at the expectation
correlation between uh YT minus V and f
x
and then uh the thing is that there are
various different multi-calibration
definitions which are all used
interchangeably for the Bad setting but
it it becomes important to understand
the nuances of these definitions for the
online setting to figure out like what
are the rates uh that we are getting for
only prediction
so L Infinity multi calibration is you
take Max over V the fraction of the
times you uh predicted value V times the
error of f comma B
and though you want this to be small and
for this La Infinity calibrium multi
calibration to make sense to be
non-trivial you you really need to care
about like what is small compared to
what is the described discretization of
PT so I won't go into those details but
then the second is L1 multi calibration
where you sum over these sum over these
values uh for B
so it is expectation would be absolute
value of this error term and this uh L1
multi-calibration uh it it makes sense
to understand this for every small
parameter because it is not it is not
trivial to achieve a small L1 multi
calibration
and then the last definition of
multi-calibration that I want to look at
is L to multi calibration which which
does expectation over V error of f comma
b square
and what previous paper on uh uh this uh
online multi-calibration gave us is L
Infinity multi calibration they gave us
an Infinity multi calibration with error
rate of 1 by square root t but there is
a log of a capital f factor which means
that the their algorithm only works for
um
finite hypothesis classes and uh and and
they are and they get L Infinity multi
calibration
so now
this does give an L1 multi calibration
after you do some post processing on
their uh on their algorithm
so which which tells us that you can get
N1 online multi-calibration with the
rate of 1 by T to the one by four uh for
finite sized hypothesis classes
and as in the batch case batch case also
uses L1 multi calibration as in the
batch case we can get online only
prediction for lipstick convex losses
through this uh through reduction to or
online L1 multi calibration
so this means that doing some massaging
over previous works we can get a 1 by T
to the one by four uh rate for a regret
rate for online only prediction uh for
finite hypothesis classes
and then the question is what about real
valued hypothesis classes where the
where the Set uh where the the size of f
can be infinite
and then the second question is can we
get better rate
now this question is very interesting
because there is a lower Bound by mingda
and Greg that showed that on L1 for L1
calibration you cannot get a better than
one by T to the 0.48 bound
so this means that if we if we want to
get online only prediction
through this through L1 online multi
calibration then we cannot get uh we we
cannot get 1 by square root T regret
that we get for loss minimizations for
many problems
okay great
we don't get better rates but we can uh
we can we make progress on this question
about like uh getting online multi
calibration and online only prediction
for uh infinite size hypothesis classes
foreign
[Music]
okay
so how we do it is we go through
um
uh we instead of developing algorithms
for L Infinity we develop algorithms for
L2 multi calibration and uh this is a
this is an algorithm that is not a min
max argument uh it goes through uh so
applicant uh guarantees
and then finally to achieve only
prediction from uh L to multiple
calibration we still go through L1 multi
calibration uh but this reduction from
L2 to L1 multi calibration is lossy so t
to the minus Alpha rate error rate L2
multi calibration implies t to the minus
Alpha by two L one multi calibration and
then this is an open problem can we get
directly get online L1 multi calibration
we don't know
okay
so very briefly about uh our L2 early
collection algorithm of L2 multi
calibration it uses uh this thing that
in batch case the recent work that
showed equivalence between loss squared
loss minimization for every lever set
and multi-calibration when both these
optimizations are done for a concept for
for a hypothesis class F which is closed
under I find transformations
and for example linear functions are
satisfies these uh this currently
and then using this equivalence we we
develop a swap regret kind of algorithm
to get L2 multi-calibration against f
plus uh capital f
uh I won't say more about this but the
idea is that we can reduce online L to
multi calibration to solving on online
squared regression error regression
problem over the class capital f
okay
so I already told you about this that
like for finite s week
we can get uh we can get uh one by two t
to the one by four online Omni
prediction regret rates and uh as this
is work in progress we are still
figuring out the exact uh sublinear
rates that we get for uh for infinite
hypothesis classes especially linear
functions uh but for infinite F we
believe that the swap regret algorithm
gives a sublinear regret for Omni
prediction uh for linear functions or
from other natural hypothesis classes
next I want to
mention that
the last time okay so yesterday
parikshit also mentioned this swap only
prediction uh uh definition he he
touched upon it very uh briefly I'm not
going to Define it but the point is that
our algorithm also gives a swap only
prediction and in their paper they
showed that swap only prediction implies
L2 multi calibration uh but uh but we we
want a strong like because we really
care about like whether it's L1 or L2
multi calibration B to to say anything
about regret rates we we wanted we
wanted to uh we we wanted to reduce it
to L1 multi-calibration and we can do
that so we can reduce swap only
prediction to L1 multi-calibration and
say that at least swap only prediction
you cannot achieve but a rate of 1 by
square root t
uh okay
uh this is all about for my talk uh I
will end with open questions the first
open question is can we achieve only
prediction with the even for finite loss
functions like I'm not even asking you
to give me for uh for the entire class
of uh convex lipsticks convex losses for
finite number of loss functions even
like two loss functions uh can we get a
regret rate of 1 by square root t
note that we need to go we'll remember
that we shouldn't try to achieve this to
L1 calibration because there is a bound
of L1 on L1 calibration so in the in in
in the in the current paper we I think
for some subclass of loss functions uh
we hint at like how we can get 1 by
square root T but I wouldn't talk about
uh that right now and then the next
question is about L1 multi-calibration
it's like can we get an oracle efficient
or even a constructive forecaster for L1
multi calibration error rate of 1 by
2302 by 3.
two by three I think even for L1
calibration people believe this is the
lower bound and uh paper by uh Foster
and Bora gave this gave a constructive
proof for L1 calibration uh but it goes
through L2 calibration so they gave that
l2k L2 calibration rate of 1 1 by T to
the one by three and that implies n l
one calibration so we can show these
like existing proof existence proofs of
L1 multi calibration with error rate of
this but is there a constructive
forecaster for we don't know how to
handle L1 multi calibration in a
constructive sense in uh in time steps
okay thank you
any questions before we break for lunch
the interest of Timeless thanks to Mega
again
no worries
it handles uh so that's kind of like
um